m
monsieur bonsoir le référendum sur la
nouvelle calédonie la campagne est
lancée
après l'allocution du premier ministre
les réactions politiques
des visites aujourd'hui au fini forte
participation dans le calme le résultat
sera-t-il respecté le conflit des
gardiens de prison en retz le cours de
la justice
ces négociations se poursuivent entre le
garde des sceaux et des syndics
c'est donc le coup d'envoi officiel qui
vient d'être donné à l'instant par le
premier ministre michel rocard
la campagne du référendum qui doit avoir
lieu le 6 novembre prochain sur la
nouvelle calédonie a commencé nous y
reviendrons en détails bien sûr avec les
réactions des principales formations
politiques à l'allocution que vous venez
d'entendre mais je vous propose d'abord
de retourner à nîmes nîmes qui deux
jours après le déluge qui a fait
officiellement huit morts est en passe
d'être déclarées en état de catastrophe
naturelle
la procédure est enclenchée à préciser
tout à l'heure le ministre de
l'intérieur pierre joxe à l'assemblée
nationale des crédits d'extrême urgence
ont été débloqués pour que la préfecture
et la mairie puisse les distribuer aux
plus démunis toute la journée les nîmois
ont dû s'habituer au bruit le bruit
assourdissant des pompes aspirantes qui
continuent d'évacuer l'eau tandis que
les secours s'organisent sur place au
hainaut l'adresse rue richelieu le
symbole du drame ni moi aujourd'hui
la rue appartient à l'armée elle seule
dispose des moyens en hommes et en
matériel pour payer les rues et les
maisons
une bonne partie des 35 mille sinistrés
que compte la cité habitait dans ce
quartier l'un des plus déshérités de la
ville ici on a tout perdu ou presque
il faut des secours immédiats est
important qu'on distribue au lait
nourriture solide et vêtements sur place
la solidarité coordonnée par la mairie
joue à plein
après il ya eu partout dans les gens de
partout
ces mises en examen dans la même maison
qu'on arrive
rien là que de couverture de pibrac bip
loi l'a passée par dessus les guides
on a fait ce qu'on a fourni plusieurs
centaines de personnes ont reçu ici une
aide matérielle ou obtenu un
renseignement sur leurs possibilités
d'indemnisation et dès demain la
répartition des secours se fera non plus
seulement à l'hôtel de ville mais aussi
dans chaque quartier pour cela on a
encore besoin d' aide supplémentaire
c'est catastrophique il faut absolument
avoir des vêtements il faut absolument
avoir de l'eau il faut absolument avoir
dit vais pas voir des denrées et nous
sommes preneurs de la totalité de ce
projet nous envoyer dans la sourde
e-sante clameur des pompes à eau
le centre de la ville reprend vie de ce
canal tout proche
on a sorti 65 véhicules et les plongeurs
encore des à cause du courant toujours
très fort s'assure qu'aucune victime n'a
disparu ce soir nîmes ville blessée
panse toujours ses plaies
le maire jean bousquet a donc mis en
place différentes commissions pour
superviser les problèmes de logement de
santé de travaux de transport scolaire
les écoles resteront fermées jusqu'à
lundi
jacques delors le président de la
commission de bruxelles pour prouver que
l'europe c'est aussi une affaire de
coeur et de solidarité a promis
aujourd'hui une aide d'urgence de près
de 3 millions de francs qui s'ajoute
donc aux sommes débloquées par le
gouvernement il faut dire qu'au delà des
drames personnels que vous venez de voir
et que vivent des milliers de personnes
c'est tout le tissu économique de la
ville qui est durablement tata ainsi
cette usine de confiture cavité rémy
ruche le silence une usine comme figé
après avoir été engloutis là encore
lundi matin l'eau a soudain surgi avec
la force d'un torrent boueux et
recouvrant tout jusqu'à 1 mètre 70 de
hauteur à 7h30 le personnel était
évacuée à la hâte et les installations
stoppées
elle ne repartiront pas avant au mieux
trois semaines sans les 400 employés
saisonniers qui ont vu leur contrat
ainsi brusquement écourtée et d'ici là
une partie des 250 membres du personnel
permanent devrait être mise au chômage
technique
ceux qui ont été les premiers à visiter
l'usiné quand l'eau est partie en ont
gardé une impression de catastrophe
complète
sinon assez rapidement même très
rapidement finalement le
le personnel a eu un sursaut une
réaction positive sur le thème on va se
mettre en quatre parce que finalement on
défend notre travail dans cette région
notre outil de production et je crois
que c'est un des éléments principaux
depuis mardi
c'est une espèce de mobilisation
générale qu'on ressent d'ailleurs dans
toute la ville mais qui est vrai au
s'initient à l' usine avec des gens qui
font beaucoup plus que ce qu'on croit
car elle qu'un être humain est capable
de faire finalement c'est un coup très
dur pour saint mamet le géant français
des fruits en conserve une partie
importante des machines et aux usages
mais surtout des centaines de milliers
de boîtes qui ont été immergées sont
devenus invendables
elles sont rouillés ou vont
immanquablement le devenir en fin de
saison de fabrication le stock était au
plus haut aujourd'hui c'est un quart de
la production qu'ils aient perdu sa
maman qui venait de réaliser de gros
investissements joue en ce moment sa
survie en réorganisant au mieux ses
programmes de livraisons car une absence
même brève de ses produits sur les
étalages et ses 40% de parts du marché
national serait immédiatement et
peut-être irrémédiablement remise en
question pour les salariés en chômage
technique et ils sont au moins 4000
l'état s'est engagé à rembourser aux
entreprises les salaires qu'elles auront
à verser pendant toute cette période et
les services fiscaux du département ont
par ailleurs reçu instruction de se
montrer indulgent quant aux délais de
paiement des impôts en matière
d'assurance le préfet du gard a annoncé
tout à l'heure que dans les communes qui
seront déclarées sinistrées
un seul imprimés simplifiée devra être
remplie quelle que soit la compagnie
d'assurance les compagnies de leur côté
se sont engagés à verser une provision
de 15 mille francs par dossier dans la
tente de l' expertise complète à mon
corps en ce qui concerne les organismes
de secours qui acheminent sur place vous
l'avez vu les vêtements les chaussures
les vivres indispensables
je vous signale l'entr'aide protestante
son numéro de ccp 23 329 27w paris avec
la mention nîmes en détresse et je vous
rappelle que demain soir à 22 heures
claude sérillon animera de nîmes
une édition spéciale consacrée en
particulier à la solidarité qui
faut déclencher et organisé de toute
urgence
hamon sur l'inquiétude des toulonnais ce
matin quand un orage violent s'est
abattu sur le centre ville en quelques
minutes 15 cm d'eau rendait les rues
impraticables et paralysé le trafic
les pompiers qui sont intervenus tout de
suite c'est en conseil des ministres ce
matin qu'a été adopté le projet de loi
référendaire sur le statut de la
nouvelle calédonie dans l'après midi le
président de l'assemblée nationale à lui
l'intitulé de la question qui vous sera
soumise le 6 novembre prochain
approuvez vous le projet de loi soumis
au peuple français par le président de
la république et portant dispositions
statutaires et préparatoire à
l'autodétermination de la nouvelle
calédonie en 1998 il s'agira bien sûr de
répondre par oui ou par non à
l'assemblée déjà avant l'allocution que
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure le
premier ministre avait insisté sur la
garantie solennelle qui sera ainsi
apporté au sort du territoire
voyons maintenant les réactions
politiques dans les rangs de
l'opposition le parti républicain dès ce
matin avait annoncé qu'il répondrait oui
avec des réserves
voyons les réactions des formations
politiques qui ont choisi de s'exprimer
sitôt après l'allocution du premier
ministre est d'abord alain juppé depuis
longtemps notre action en nouvelle
calédonie a été inspiré par deux soucis
prioritaires
le premier c'est de respecter la volonté
de nos concitoyens qui habite là-bas ils
l'ont exprimé très clairement il y a un
an environ dans un référendum
d'autodétermination où la très large
majorité des électeurs a choisi de
rester français ce référendum là c'est
aussi la parole de la france et nous
entendons qu'elle soit respectée
notre deuxième souci c'est la volonté de
paix il y a eu depuis le début des
années 80 des troubles graves en
nouvelle calédonie et l'action des
gouvernements socialistes de l'époque
année largement responsables nous
n'avons donc aucune leçon à recevoir en
la matière
j'ai envoyé très récemment une mission
en nouvelle-calédonie
elle m'a rapporté deux messages le
premier c'est que nos compatriotes ont
signé ces accords parce qu'ils veulent
la paix comme nous le deuxième message
c'est qu'ils sont inquiets et qu'ils
nous demandent notre vigilance
ils craignent que les socialistes
n'aient pas changé ils craignent la
partialité de l'état dans l'application
de ces accords
eh bien nous répondrons à leur appel et
cela nous guidera dans le choix que nous
arrêterons définitivement comme prévu le
15 octobre prochain après celle du rpr
d'autres réactions et d'abord celle de
jean marie tjibaou le président du fln
caisse et jacques lafleur du rpr avait
déjà donné leur accord à une
modification du texte adopté en conseil
des ministres ils étaient reçus tout à
l'heure par le président du cds pierre
méhaignerie jean marie tjibaou
moi je vais essayer seulement des faits
une campagne d'explication sur les
enjeux je mets mobiliser les français ce
sont les responsables français qui
peuvent opposer les faces et moi je n'ai
pas de compétence quoi pour leur dire
oui de voter oui ou non j'explique
seulement les enjeux en disant que c'est
important
bon je pense que les français prennent
conscience de cela et j'espère que tu
fais l'amour étant comme ça ils n'ont
pas la pêche mais qu'ils iront voter
j'ai l'impression d'avoir convaincu me
suis amélioré de faire campagne pour ce
référendum
je suis mignard et c'est un ancien
ministe c'est un député c'est pas moi
qui viens de la brousse travail qu'ils
vivent âge qu'il faut faire
d'autres réactions encore que nous
aurons peut-être au cours de ce journal
mais passons maintenant à l'analyse
politique le président d'un public qui
ce matin a demandé à l'ensemble des
gouvernements de s'engager dans la
campagne quant à lui ils pourraient au
moment qu'il jugera opportun s'adresser
à l'opinion mais c'est bien l'artisan
des accords de matignon c'est à dire le
premier ministre qui est monté dès ce
soir en première ligne gilles leclerc il
renoncer au référendum ce serait
renoncer à l'accord lui même cette
phrase prononcée par le président de la
république avant même les cantonales
avaient déjà levé tout suspense quoi que
l'opposition ait pu dire depuis
ainsi à partir d'aujourd'hui nous
entrons dans la phase finale du
processus référendaire
et si françois mitterrand s'est exprimé
ce matin en conseil des ministres avant
de prendre sans doute d'autres
initiatives c'est bien michel rocard qui
vient d'entamer la campagne pour le oui
mission du dialogue accords matignon
voyage en nouvelle calédonie le premier
ministre s'est investie en lançant
solennellement on l'a vu cette fois un
appel à la mobilisation avec à ses yeux
la formule clé de paix civile
michel rocard s'attaque au risque
d'abstention en s'efforçant de mettre
l'opposition au pied du mur
à cet égard les références souligné par
deux fois à la signature de jacques
lafleur rpcr sont claires l'objectif du
gouvernement sera d'échapper à la
formule traditionnelle référendum
plébiscite tout en obtenant un taux de
participation raisonnable de l'ordre
sans doute de 40%
principal artisan donc du succès de la
première étape consacrée au dossier
néo-calédonien michel rocard tente
maintenant de franchir la seconde il
sera ou non aidé par une opposition qui
devra maintenant se déterminer tout à
fait clairment alors justement j'ai deux
réactions politiques encore celle de
bernard stasi et de bruno mégret
si rocard trompent les français il leur
fait croire qu'il s'agit de la paix
civile
c'est faux en réalité ils organisent
l'indépendance du territoire de nouvelle
calédonie nous pensons que c'est une
mauvaise chose pour la france
et l'enjeu est maintenant clair d'un
côté la classe politicienne les tenants
du oui qui veulent l'abandon de la
nouvelle calédonie et qui propose une
politique de renoncement de démission et
de déclin de l'autre les tenants du non
le front national pour une politique de
grandeur et de puissance de la france ma
première réaction c'est de confirmer la
position qui a toujours été la mienne
est toujours été celle du cds c'est à
dire nous sommes pour le oui nous
considérons que les français doivent
répondre au oui non pas du tout au
gouvernement non pas du tout aux prisons
de la république
mais oui à la paix oui aux accords entre
tjibaou et la fleur
oui l évolution pacifique de la nouvelle
calédonie alors il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'une campagne politique il
faut aussi sur le terrain préparer
l'avenir c'est dans cet esprit que les
accords de matignon ont prévu des stages
de formation pour que les calédoniens et
surtout les mélanésiens est à terme
leurs propres cadres administratifs un
tout premier stage est ainsi en cours à
besançon stéphane magnier sur le mur de
la salle de classe une photo pour
rappeler d'où l'on vient et un peu plus
tard le plateau la cantine qui montre où
l'on naît deux images qui témoigne de
l'effort d'adaptation encore nécessaire
aujourd'hui
dix jours après leur arrivée au 15
femmes et 10 hommes participant au stage
au programme de la gestion publique du
droit de la comptabilité de la
communication bref un menu classique
d'un futur cadre supérieur
d'administration
jusqu'ici ça a toujours été la gestion
surtout par des tendinites aux
conducteurs c'est pour ça que dans
beaucoup de cadres métropolitains sur un
territoire et c'est un peu pour prouver
qu'on est capable
de gérer d'un pays quoi bon si ça le
stage est prise en charge par les
ministère des dom tom et d'épée le
centre de formation de la poste avait la
capacité à gérer cette formation est
assurée agir vite pour conquérir ce qui
est aussi un marché à terme de 400
stagiaires à condition bien sûr que
cette première expérience soit une
réussite
ce que voudrait c'est qu'ici on va vous
apprendre une gestion moderne de
l'administration et j'espère que on me
mettra dans un service où on pourrait
appliquer ce que j'ai appris ici
malheureusement ça ne suit pas toujours
parce qu'il ya un tel décalage des fois
au niveau administratif pas du
territoire par rapport à la métropole
qui fait que j'ai encore beaucoup de
choses qui ne sont pas modernisé dans
notre pays
besançon offre l'avantagé d'être un peu
à l'écart des patients politique tout en
facilitant l'intégration locale une
tranquillité nécessaire pour des gens
qui n'ont pas été sélectionnés sur des
critères scolaires
si tous ont au moins le bac ils ont été
choisi à titre individuel par l'une des
grandes tendances politiques néo
calédonienne partisans et adversaires de
l'indépendance se retrouvent donc
content à côte
confronté à un débat sur lesquels ils
préfèrent rester discrets car il peut se
révéler aussi bien explosif que
bénéfique
je trouve formidable parce que je vis
dans une premier de l'intérieur et je
trouve que suite aux accords de matignon
ça nous permettrait de mieux se
connaître ce que pour moi
personnellement les problèmes qu'à nice
et les problèmes humains et je pense que
en vivons ensemble on connaîtra mieux la
vie de l'année vient la vie
les dix autres ethnies et je pense que
c'est très important
la discussion à l'assemblée nationale et
en coulisses des modalités du revenu
minimum d'insertion se poursuit
les socialistes ont insisté pour qu'il
soit étendu aux moins de 25 ans ayant
charge de famille et aux étrangers en
situation régulière
l'unique député du front national
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'elle voterait le
texte comme les autres groupes de
l'opposition que le front national avait
pourtant critiqué par ailleurs les
négociations tendues continue entre le
ministère de la justice et les syndicats
de gardiens de prison
le garde des sceaux a indiqué ce soir
qu'ils nommaient gilbert bonnemaison
députés verts socialistes et spécialiste
de ces problèmes
à la tête d'une mission d'étude mais en
attendant le processus voici gilbert
bonnemaison
mais en attendant le processus de la
justice est grippé les avocats n'ont
plus accès à leurs clients certains
procès sont reportés notamment aux
assises du rhône claude régent a enquêté
à lyon beaucoup de pas perdus
aujourd'hui au palais de justice de lyon
le banc des accusés est resté vide deux
hommes poursuivis pour meurtres sont
restés en prison
l'audience de la cour d'assises a été
renvoyé
des surveillants de la maison d'arrêt
comparaître au procès n'ont pas pu être
observé une journée perdue pour une
justice déjà grippée les témoins les
jurés les magistrats se sont déplacés
pour rien et les avocats se plaignent de
la paralysie de la justice pour nous
c'est très gênant parce que cela
constitue tous les jours une violation
de droits de la défense
on peut pas assurer normalement la
défense de gens qui ne viennent pas dans
ceux qui ne peuvent pas être jugés alors
certains devraient être mis en liberté
car il ya quand même le problème de la
liberté qui joue cela tant qu'on ne peut
pas les juger ils ne sont pas mis en
liberté autre conséquence spectaculaire
de la grève la transformation par arrêté
ministériel de l'hôtel de police en
maison d'arrêt depuis hier les prévenus
sont incarcérés dans les cellules de
garde à vue et surveillés par des
policiers
la solution ne peut être que temporaire
car les détenus arrivent au rythme de 10
par jour
or il ya en tout et pour tout 70 places
à l'hôtel de police et dans les
commissariats de la ville
les grévistes eux sont toujours à
déterminer
c'est sûr la situation se dégrade par
rapport au système judiciaire aussi
samba police puisque
actuellement les écrous sont faits dans
les commissariats de police
mais nous sommes conscients des
problèmes que ça occasionne mais nous
irons jusqu'au bout nos revendications
il n'est pas question pour nous en tant
que personnel pénitencier de nous
arrêter simplement des promesses unique
concession des surveillants les parloirs
pour les familles ont été maintenues
mais les visites sont limitées à la demi
heure légale une réaction politique
encore à l'allocution du premier
ministre sur la nouvelle calédonie et
nous parviennent un peu au fur et à
mesure celle de jean claude gaudin
l'intervention du premier ministre a
bien démarré
personne ne peut rester insensible aux
poignées de mains entre monsieur lafleur
et monsieur tjibaou
mais le reste est tout à fait discutable
et lorsque le premier ministre dit qu'il
ya eu manquement à la parole donnée de
la france en 1963 par le général de
gaulle ou en 1986 cela me paraît relever
de l'expression même du président de la
république la force elle juste de la loi
et cela me paraît tout à fait
inacceptables quant à la fin mai le
premier ministre demande un engagement
un engagement à soutenir sa politique et
celle du président de la république
référendum référendum et plébiscitent
cela nous paraît tout à fait contestable
nous c'était oui à l'accord non à la
procédure alors nous verrons dans les
jours qui viennent
la réponse que nous donnerons voilà donc
pour ce tour d'horizon des réactions
politiques
l'allocution de michel rocard garde à
vue prolongée pour le directeur et les
trois moniteurs du camp scout qui avait
accueilli la petite delphine retrouvés
carbonisés dans leur il y à un mois des
informations complémentaires ont été
demandées aux gendarmes de caen qui
avait dû enquêter l'an dernier sur un
assassinat de même nature celui d'une
autre petite fille de 11 ans si au nom à
cette question simple oui ou non qu'on
ne l'avait plus posée depuis 15 ans les
chignin sont en train de répondre en
masse
il est 6 heures plus tôt là bas le
plébiscite qui doit décider du sort du
régime du général pinochet est en train
de se jouer dans le calme la nuit
dernière pourtant des coupures
courant inexpliquée avait inquiété la
population à santiago aujourd'hui
bernard benyamin à accompagner l'une de
ceux qui surveillent la bonne tenue du
scrutin
la soeur d'un ancien ministre d' alien
dès 6h du matin
une torche à la main mathilde sort de
chez elle hier soir une série
d'explosions a privé d'électricité
une bonne moitié du chili voit lui dans
quelles conditions je vais voter sans
lumière j'ai dû descendre les douze
étages a plié
ça te démontrer un peu ce qui va se
passer aujourd'hui c'est la soeur de
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture de
salvador-allende actions de sol elle a
été élue présidente de l'un des bureaux
de vote de la reine à son quartier
une désignation démocratique d'autant
que ses opinions anti pinochet ne sont
un secret pour personne le nom le
problème c'est qu est ce qui va se
passer parce que le seul fait que la
nuit la lumière est dégroupé qu'il y
avait une quantité énorme de bombes
partout dans toute la ville de san diego
et il ya eu des avions alors tout le
monde commence à avoir peur alors les
gens vont voter avec deux avec la peur 8
heures du matin le jour se lève sur
santiago
l'un de ces jours qui pourrait bien
marquer l'histoire moderne du chili
l'armée présente dans la rue
quinze mille hommes répartis dans tout
le pays pour assurer la bonne marche du
scrutin elle est aussi présente dans
tous les bureaux de vote et dans et
renseignant les 7 millions et demi de
chiliens inscrits sur les registres
électoraux et là encore on a du mal à
comprendre ce régime militaire dit
jouent le jeu de la démocratie
acceptant apparemment d'être la
principale victime d'un processus qu'il
a lui-même enclenchée en tout cas les
queues sont interminables devant tous
les bureaux de vote
autour de mathilde ses assesseurs dont
le travail est sévèrement contrôlé par
des jeunes femmes ce sont les délégués
des partis politiques leur garantie
contre les risques de fraude même
spectacle dans tout le chili au stade
national par exemple de sinistre mémoire
ces hauts lieux de la dictature pourrait
bien devenir tout à l'heure l'un des
symboles de la démocratie
c'est la fin de trois heures de santiago
que devraient être connues les grandes
tendances de ce plébiscite
si c'est le oui qui gagne le général
pinochet resterait au pouvoir jusqu'en
mais le désespoir des milliers de
chiliens risque fort de s'exprimer ce
soir dans la rue si c'est le nom qu'ils
emportent la constitution prévoit la
tenue d'élections présidentielles d'ici
à un an
mais dans ce cas la célébration de la
victoire pourrait bien se transformer en
manifestation contre le régime place
dans les deux cas de figure la nuit
risque d'être mouvementée à santiago et
c'est dans télématin que vous aurez en
direct de santiago les résultats du
référendum invité gérard morin aux 4
vérités sergio bitar un ancien ministre
d' alien d une opération estimation à
l'échelle internationale a été lancée
par la sofres l'institut de sondage
français avec entre autres la
participation de l'événement du jeudi et
bien voici les tendances que l'on vient
de me faire connaître à l'instant une
tendance nette en faveur du non au
général pinochet
après dépouillement de plus de 2000 des
cinq mille questionnaires donc établi au
chili par 125 équipes de sondeurs
certains d'entre eux ont d'ailleurs été
brutalisés à l'occasion les chiliens de
paris ont manifesté en fin de journée
devant l'ambassade de leur pays
pas de doute pas beaucoup de doutes sur
l'unanimité de leur vote
e éruption de colère à alger aujourd'hui
dans la plupart des quartiers
manifestations violentes des jeunes
surtout rue des vitrines saccagées au
téléphone les précisions du
correspondant de l'afp sur place
garder leur pouvoir politique du fln
convoqué d'urgence par le président
chadli a condamné ces manifestations et
annoncé une pointe de fer sur l'ordre
public
une autre manifestation sans précédent à
belgrade en yougoslavie emmanuel vanier
nous avons été trompés c'était le slogan
de ces deux mille ouvriers rassemblés
devant le parlement fédéral à belgrade
selon un manifestant les forces de
l'ordre les avaient empêchés de se
joindre au mouvement de six autres
entreprises locales autorisés à pénétrer
à l'intérieur du parlement les
manifestants ont réclamé des réformes
sociales immédiates
face à ce mécontentement social
croissant dû notamment à une inflation
atteignant les 200 %
les autorités yougoslave ont annoncé un
renouvellement important des instances
dirigeantes du pays quatre morts plus de
500 blessés c'est la deuxième
catastrophe ferroviaire du même type en
l'espace de quatre mois en union
soviétique
l'explosion de deux wagons chargés de
produits dangereux s'est produite lundi
soir dans l'oural huit immeubles et 12
maisons détruites il y a plusieurs
milliers de sans abri un quotidien local
a accusé les forces de défense civile de
ne pas être intervenue avec assez de
rapidité et d'efficacité il le
poursuivra encore et toujours c'est la
terrible histoire d'une douleur et d'une
vengeance à londres le père d'un
adolescent tué par un chauffard il ya
six ans a réussi à confondre
l'automobiliste mais le jugement des
hommes ne l'a pas satisfait philippe
harrouard timothy proctor 14 ans est
tuée en 1982 par un chauffard ivre sur
une route du serait le chauffard gordon
stratton et condamné à neuf mois de
prison et quatre ans et demi de
suspension de permis pour le père de
timothy bernard proctor c'est révoltant
il ne peut accepter le verbe
il décide de faire quelque chose pendant
cinq ans bernard proctor va traquer le
meurtrier de son fils à sa sortie de
prison il y consacre tout son temps et
une partie de son argent
douze fois il va filmer ou photographier
stratton au volant d'une voiture ou
d'une camionnette
malgré le retrait de permis il le trac à
la sortie des peuples prouvant qu'il
boit toujours les preuves accumulées
sont telles que stratton repasse
finalement en justice c'était hier et
straton a été condamnée à nouveau à neuf
mois de prison et à un an de retrait de
permis
monsieur proctor n'est pas satisfait un
an sans permis c'est dix fois moins que
ce qu'il attendait alors pour lui
l' affaire n'est pas terminée car comme
ils le répètent inlassablement cas
personne ne lui rendra son fils amateurs
de football sachez qu'il vous faudra
attendre minuit sur antenne 2 pour
suivre en différé le match anderlecht
mais ce qui compte pour la coupe des
vainqueurs de coupe la ligue nationale
de football nous interdit de le diffuser
plus tôt les pronostics de pierrette
brès rapidement pour le quarté de demain
à saint cloud le 12 le 6 le 8 le 5 le 3e
1 le 9 et le 4 dans un instant le temps
avec laurent cabrol et puis un mot pour
saluer la réapparition du magazine globe
victimes vous le savez d'un attentat en
juillet dernier le magazine avec une
nouvelle maquette et un dossier sur les
années 90 les nerfs édition de notre
journal à minuit avec philippe lefait
merci d'avoir suivi celui ci à demain 20
heures